[Music]
they show up uninvited
they shake your whole body and they can
travel up to 160 kilometres an hour when
you sneeze all the muscles in your body
react from your eyelids right down to
your sphincter do you hate sneezing in
awkward situations are you scared of
spreading germs well what would happen
if you held in all your sneezes to
figure this one out we have to ask how
does sneezing actually work and what
would happen to us if we did hold in our
sneezes this is what if and here's what
would happen screaming this is what if
and here's what would happen if you held
in all your sneezes a sneeze has the
role of getting anything out of your
nose and sinuses that shouldn't be there
that could be anything from pepper to
dust to perfume even pet dander the
official name for sneezing is stern
mutation during the act of sneezing your
body is building up pressure in your
respiratory system your lungs throat and
sinuses are shaking in suspense sneezes
are involuntary when we an uninvited
guest shows up in your sinuses the red
flags go up and convulsions in the
airway rock at the air house
otolaryngologists know'm cohen of the
university of pennsylvania compared it
to fixing a computer error he says it's
like resetting the system like Control
Alt Delete in 2002 a study at Denmark's
Department of Otolaryngology at Riggs
hospital ER showed that 95 percent of
people sneeze four times or less each
day worldwide we could be sneezing
upwards of seven point eight billion
times a day so what would happen if we
tried to hold them in
infectious diseases such as whooping
cough the common cold and the flu can
all be spread by sneezing if you were to
hold your sneezes in we could be
stopping the spread of several diseases
but we wouldn't recommend it when you
hold in a sneeze you're putting up to 24
times more pressure on the respiratory
system then if you just let it out
possible injuries from trying not to
sneeze include pulled muscles burst
eardrums and ruptured blood vessels in
the eyes it can do some serious damage
and result in serious complications for
your body including pneumomediastinum
which is air becoming trapped between
your lungs and the rupture of a cerebral
aneurysm cases have also been reported
of a held in sneeze causing globs of
infected mucus to be slammed through the
eustachian tube and into the middle ear
bringing an infection along with it for
the ride maybe you should just let that
sneeze out in 2018 a man in Britain was
admitted to hospital after he attempted
to stifle a sneeze the attempt resulted
in rupturing the back of his throat he
also managed to Terrace pharynx which is
what connects your mouth and nasal
cavity to your esophagus doctors found
that air from the man's lungs had
managed to bubble into his deep tissue
and chest muscles once there it had no
way to get out again this poor guy was
hospitalized for a week and required a
feeding tube and intravenous antibiotics
just to help with the pain and swelling
if we held in all our sneezes this could
go from being a medical rarity to a
common occurrence and what would your
world look like if you held in
well the phrase bless you would rarely
be uttered outside of a church pepper
suppliers would see a small dip in their
business and doctors might see a big
drop in cases of the common cold virus
however they'd see a lot more patients
with beet red eyes from their blood
vessels bursting sneezing is a very
simple everyday action that almost
everyone does
it's a bodily function we take for
granted it may be annoying but if you
force sneezing out of the picture life
becomes a lot more complicated a sneeze
takes a fraction of a second the same
amount of time it may take to land in
the hospital if you try holding it in so
it's best to just let it happen and wipe
your nose instead did you know that
there's research showing that a sneeze
can release endorphins the same way an
orgasm camp
what if orgasms didn't exist in the
first place now that's a story for
another what
[Music]